Hello and welcome
to metal Mondays.
Well, I am joined by two fabulous colleagues.
One of them has decided to take a
little break at the last minute and I'm
just gonna bring him in now.
I decided not to show your empty chair
Jeremy because this is professional
feature and we do not have that kind
of thing around here.
Happy Monday.
I've also joined oh, I haven't actually introduced
anyone. I'm joined by two wonderful colleagues from
Equinix Medal, Tom Crow and Jeremy Tanner. Welcome
friends.
Thank you. Thanks, Macay.
So
who wants to
explain to our wonderful viewers what we're gonna
be doing today?
Sure. We're gonna basically start at the very
entry point into Equinix metal and we're gonna
show you how to spin up your your
servers
and what information you can get out of
those. We're gonna go through three stages of
that. We're gonna look at how to do
it through the UI,
what what you get through there.
Then we're gonna delve into the API and
look at the power of the CLI.
That sounds awesome.
So I think this is gonna be a
regular feature by the three of us here.
Metal Mondays may not be the working title
name and this is very much ad hoc
and off the cuff this evening. But we
do have some really good content to show
you. Like Tom says, we're gonna introduce you
to spinning up metal with Equinix metal through
the three different avenues.
And I think the plan is, is that
Tom here is gonna walk us through using
the user interface of the console. The
clicky approach, click ops to spin an upper
metal. We're then gonna go into a slightly
deeper dive with Jeremy who's gonna show us
how to use the XMetal
API to provision infrastructure.
And then I'm gonna phone it in with
a really quick demo of the CLI and
show you how you can just use the
the packet tools that are available on the
terminal to do something very similar to the
API, but hopefully a little bit easier.
With that being said, if I can get
you Tom to share your screen,
we'll start with the ClickOps.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
There we go. Alright. Here is our landing
page. When you get your account up and
running on Equinix Medal, this is what you're
gonna see. If you have questions about the
servers
and how things work, click right here, get
some help, open up to our
server's docs. But let's go ahead and get
started. Let's just spin up our first server.
And for this purpose, we're gonna go ahead
and pick up an on demand server.
If you wanna ensure that you have the
that you have this the hardware you need
for growth and,
scale.
The only way we can really guarantee that
is reserve. But for what we're doing right
now, we can do a quick on demand
server.
And I am gonna go with
our
New York
off oh, I am not gonna go with
New York.
So we'll go with our Dallas. That's closest
to Jeremy and I, actually halfway between the
two of us.
And for this,
I'm just gonna do a c three medium,
which, you can see in the c in
the UI, you can tell exactly what all
the specs are for your devices that you're
looking for in the data in which data
center. I think this is really cool stuff
about the the plans that we have available
as well. It's like, not only do we
have some pretty awesome chunky bare metal hardware,
there's also a lot of ARM chips in
there too.
There are. You can
as you look through, you can see, like,
our c one large ARM. If you wanna
play with the ARM, we know that's gonna
be a bigger player in the in the
hardware space in the coming years.
But for right now, like I said, we'll
just go with the c three, and I'm
gonna deploy cent CentOS seven.
When you're looking, you can see you can
bring your own
IPXC image. You can do Debian. You can
do Ubuntu. You can do so you can
do pretty much anything you want.
I am going to unlike every other time
I've deployed, I'm gonna remember to to change
the name here.
We're gonna call it metal both mean.
Metal Monday.
It means that this operating system is faster
than the others here. So you can see
that Ubuntu
and, CentOS both deploy in sixty seconds. So
once I hit once I hit go, we
can start our timer and see how we're
doing. I'm gonna go on and just do
everything by default to keep things simple for
us and deploy now.
Alright. You're on the clock.
Right here we can see It
looks like one or more of our new
instances is waiting for something else to deprovision.
And now we're actually going. You can see
the spinning wheel letting us know that it's
provisioning.
One thing I like in the UI, you
can click here and see exactly what stage
of the
provisioning process you're in. Right now, we've hit
9% and we're setting our network configuration. You
can see the entire path that this
hardware is gonna go before it's up and
running.
Third thirty seconds. Twenty
seven percent.
I feel like I'm I'm under the gun
here, y'all. I I may have promised more
than I could more than I can deliver
here.
Well, the lightning bolt might made some promises.
It did. It did.
Yeah. The light at all is is quite
accurate. I found that, you know, maybe not
consistently under sixty seconds, but it's consistently fast
for those operating systems. And it really just
depends on the the facility that you choose.
You did pick one of the default facilities
Dallas Fort Fort Worth, which is obviously got
a lot going on. So sometimes it can
be a little bit slower.
Right. But it just depends on facility, what
capacity is available, which type of machine you
you chose.
There are many different conditions, but still it
will be fast. Maybe not sixty seconds, but
it will be fast.
Alright.
And then not not a CentOS emergency.
No. Definitely not. And then, you know, the
next few what, dots? Oh, there you I
was gonna say, the They go really quickly.
Fast.
They are. But I think for what we're
used to with deploying servers,
you know, you would you would start deploying,
walk off, go grab your coffee, talk to
your coworker, come back, check-in.
We're definitely not in those days anymore with
this.
No. And now the machine is is just
rebooting. So the operating system has already been
provisioned. And now it's just a case of
that machine spinning back up, loading the kernel,
and and giving you a a shell if
you want it, which is good.
Alright. We are up and running. We can
see that here. Under actions, we do have
details that we can get. We can go
here and get all of the the IP
addresses for our
machine. You'll notice that there's an SSH root
password. This is when you if you're gonna
tunnel in to your device, you can copy
this and use it for the first twenty
four hours while you get everything set up.
Down here, we can see exactly what hardware
we have. We can look at the twenty
four hour traffic. Obviously, we haven't done anything
with this server yet, so there's no traffic.
We can set up our SSH keys.
Nope.
See who see all the SSH keys that
are tied to it.
One thing I also like, we have built
into everything is this rescue OS. If something
goes wrong and our server is not performing
the way it should or not communicating,
we can do a rescue OS and recover
recover the hardware.
And
have a question if you're happy to take
it, Tom. We do. What is it?
So
Vikram has asked, can we explain why Equinix
Metal is different to Digital Ocean?
Yeah. So Equinix Metal, you're actually the you're
getting the full hardware. You're not getting some,
you know, something you're not getting a a
droplet wrapped up as part of a hardware.
You actually have all the way down to
the very base basic level of of this
hardware. You can, put whatever you want. There
are no assumptions that are built into what
you may or may not need in your
stack or how it should be provisioned. You're
making every decision and have a lot more
a lot more control over
your infrastructure than you do with other providers.
Yeah. I would say, quite simply, there is
one of you on one machine,
and, that's bare metal.
You with, with other providers, often the situation
is you're on a virtual machine. There may
be,
n of you, usually n being many,
all on the same machine with a, subdivided
into a little virtual machine chunks, which appears
to be its own computer, but it's not
a real computer.
Which Without the whole matrix background of what
is real.
Which can become problematic if one of if
if something's going wrong with somebody else's drop
or somebody else's
environment on on the same server, you can
start having noisy neighbor problems, have performance issues.
Here, you know exactly what you have reserved
for yourself and you know what space you
have, and that's all dedicated a % to
you.
We went ahead,
before I pass off to Jeremy, what we
would normally do here is we would go
grab,
and create an API key. Jeremy's already got
that. So with that, I'm gonna pass it
over to you, Jeremy, and let you show
them what they can do with the API.
I
went to remove your screen talking to Jeremy.
That's
not the time to run away, Jeremy.
Alright. We're going to
give a look at the Equinix metal project
right here. Perfect.
So, for this, to demonstrate these features, I'm
going to use my favorite API explorer,
which is Paw for macOS.
And the first thing is I'm going to
look for the,
decide before I, bring up a machine, what
operating system I'm going to want to use.
The operating system's endpoint,
you can give a look, and then that
will,
bring back the
full list of the operating systems that are
available,
the UUID that we're using for them, their,
their version,
and and so on.
And so if you use,
j q to filter that list to just
the names of the operating system,
there are 58 different OSs that we have
available for you to
put on these,
machines.
In addition to, you can, bring your own,
on this. I believe that's the,
custom IPXC,
and you can, so
50 so 56
because one of them is
is called deep revision
up here, which is actually the the the
reverse of putting operating system onto a machine.
And
all the all the rest of them are.
And then, you can also you can also
bring your own if you would like. And
so, once we decide which operating system we'll
use,
how about,
how about Ubuntu 20
we'll go with?
And then we'll look for plans,
which is
what we call our different
our different machine types.
And so you're going to see the very
much the same things that you saw in
the dashboard.
You're going to be able to see here.
And so the the names of the machines,
the sizes of them, how much memory,
what sort of, sort of drives are inside
them,
which,
how many NICs at at what speed they
have,
and,
what they're going to cost for your particular
account to use. And so,
for this particular machine,
the,
the two a four, that's going to be,
50¢ an hour.
And then,
the final part of, deciding what we what
we want is going to be which which
facility we put that in. And so at
the facilities endpoint, you're able to look and
see all of the different
facilities
that
we
we have available to you. Your account may
show,
more or fewer depending on, what the, what
the permissions on it are.
Those are the names of all the
facilities we're using.
They're all given the, they're all given the
code,
counting upwards of the nearest airport to that
data center.
And then
your
these list of servers in the dashboard is
is very similar to the
what you're going to get when you call
a git on devices,
and that's going to bring back all of
the machines
that are currently
on that in that particular project.
So Tom did not kill
the
the one that he brought up, and so
you can now see all of the information
associated with the
the device that Tom made and called it
demo metal Monday.
It's assigned to him.
If you're if you're sharing this account, you're
able to see who brought a particular
machine up, so you're able to then contact
them if you have if you have questions
about it.
That's seven.
And then all of the rest of the
you'll have the list of SSH keys that
are
that are on that machine so that you'll
know who's able to who's able to easily
get into it.
Again, where it is, that one's up in
Dallas,
and all of the rest of the information.
So don't have to show bringing one up,
but we
very quite easily can. Bringing up a machine
is done by
sending just a few bits of information
to that same
devices endpoint,
but as opposed instead of a as opposed
instead of a get. And you're going to
want to say what facility you're putting something
into, or you can give it the word
any in case you want to in case
you want to leave it up to us
where
where that machine is. And then we have
the UUID for the particular
machine that you've chosen,
the UUID for the particular operating
system you've chosen. This one corresponds with Ubuntu
20.
You can give tags.
You can give your machine a host name.
When you hit the off you go button,
you know, get a two zero one response,
which means we've,
we've gone ahead and started, but we're, that
machine isn't up quite yet.
When we, when we run git devices again,
there should be a
not a four zero four, but a 200.
That's what we're looking for.
And now there are two items in our
Git devices. We have metal Monday being the
first one, and then we have the API
test device one,
which I just made.
And then
that'll have all the information about it. So
provisioning percentage,
that's the same sort of thing that you
were looking at in the dashboard where we
went from, I think, 27, 20 one percent
up to 90. If you're looking for the
exact
if you're looking for the exact steps,
you can get that through
looking for
there'll be provisioning events inside that JSON, and
then the body of those is what so,
yeah, first step is provisioning started,
network configured,
connected to magic install system, OS system, server
partitions created, then all the way through the
eleventh step, which is device phone home and
is ready to go.
And if we
refresh this,
that probably means
that
it's now at, yeah, it's now at 90%.
The machine is
should be rebooting now.
Mhmm.
And
Tom can probably see that in his
in his dashboard.
And
I suppose the final final portion is to
is to then remove that is to then
remove that device
once it's up. Or
I could just take and remove Tom's
after getting verbal confirmation from Tom, but that's
okay, and he's not in the, in the
midst of doing anything on it.
As we've learned, that verbal confirmation is very
important.
Go ahead and tear that one down.
Alright. That's the first device. There's its ID.
Take and copy that key over that
UUID for Tom's device that's in Dallas over
to
the,
again, the device's endpoint, but in this case,
going to
send it a delete.
Two zero four, no content, which is exactly
what we were expecting.
And now when I go back to get
devices,
instead of two items, I have just the
one item,
API test device one
and,
Tom's, which I believe he called Metal Monday,
is now gone,
gone forever.
And if I look back at
the API test device one,
the state is now active instead of provisioning.
And so
that Ubuntu 20 machine is up and
ready to go. And you can see the
same sorts of things that you'd see in
that
that you'd be seeing in the in the
dashboard. It's internal and external IPs,
the list of SSH keys that are able
to reach that
that are able to reach that machine.
Since I said any, and it was a
it was roulette as to where it ended
up, this one is in the the New
York 5
data center that's in
Secaucus, New Jersey.
And
what else have we got in here? All
kinds of good stuff. Anything else you want?
That's a this machine happened to be a
happens to be a c three small, an
eight core Xeon.
But with that, I think we can
unless
I'm a guy who wouldn't
let's
let's not delete this one also.
Yeah. I've already provisioned my production website on
it, so let's not do that.
Alright. We'll leave that, we'll leave that up
and available for now.
But that is both bringing up and bringing
down
Awesome.
You. The API.
So if you wanna learn more about using
our API and there are some use cases
for using the API over using UI or
CLI, we'll maybe talk about that just after
my quick demonstration. But we have really decent
documentation, really good documentation, sell it better David.
Then you can go to metals.equinox.com/developers/API
and all of the endpoints that Jeremy was
using there are listed with the parameters that
you need to have it in etcetera.
Now what I wanna do is show you
how to use the CLI application. So
you can
download the packet CLI and run it as
packet CLI here.
And the first thing we're gonna try and
do then is see if we can list
Jeremy's machine.
Now to do that, we're gonna use the
device
sub command
which has a few options here. So we
also have the ability to create a device
like Jeremy did. We also have the ability
to delete Jeremy's device which I'll hopefully do
in a moment. We can reboot, start, stop,
update, etcetera. You can see all the sub
commands there and for all the sub commands,
you have the option of passing dash dash
help and it'll just tell you which parameters
are available and what flags are available to
manipulate that data.
What I wanna do is try and list
all of the devices
and see if we can see Jeremy's.
And
I need a project ID. No. Did I
copy that ahead of time?
Well, I probably did but now I've lost
it. So let's do
j q dot demo.
Yeah. I planned ahead. I've got a project
scale and
if I ask for that without quotes
PB copy, I should get that back into
my buffer. Now if I run devices get
project filter with that,
you can actually see the API call is
very similar to what Jeremy was using with
Paul. Like There is. ID,
I see the host name, I can see
the operating system and the fact that it's
active and it was created only a few
minutes ago.
So I'm gonna copy this ID
and I'm gonna delete it. Which
oh, I can't see. I I can't remember
the ID. Is it dash d? It's
dash I. Woah. What happened to my legs?
Okay. So we're gonna pass and delete with
the device ID.
And it's gonna ask me if I want
to confirm, yes or no.
And my daughter is banging on my door.
I don't know if you can hear that.
I'm
I'm having some flashbacks watching one of Jeremy's
servers getting deleted.
Are you sure are you sure your daughter
wasn't running something on that a bunch of
bucks?
Very possibly. So what we see here is
the device deletion was initiated.
And if we run get in fact, I
wasn't even fast enough because we're too busy
laughing at door being banged. But we can
see that device has already disappeared.
Other use cases in the CLI, we also
have the ability to view the plans. So
we can see all the same plans that
Jeremy was able to pull back. So everything
we could do for the API, we can
also do for the CLI. And there are
different use cases for when you want to
use one or the other. Like,
maybe we could talk about that briefly before
we finish up then. Yeah. So
do you guys, CLI and API? What, when
and where? And I won't get any opinions
on that.
I'll go first.
So
for me, think the UI is good for
any new product. If you're new to Equinix
metal and you just wanna go to the
console, spin up something and really, know, just
wanna vanilla up into a machine and you
just wanna get on a SSHN and start
kicking the tires a bit. The AI is
probably the easiest way to do that and
it requires no upfront knowledge. You don't need
to know the API or the CLI.
For automation stuff, I'd probably jump straight to
the API before the CLI.
You know, if I wanna be able to
like see for a continuous integration or test
room, I wanna spin up a device provision
of the stuff. Then API is probably the
way to go forward for that. The CLI,
I'm not sure if there's a de facto
use case I would go for it. I
mean personally, I prefer the API, I'm comfortable
with that tooling, but the CLI is available
for there if you know,
it's probably good for debugging, I guess actually.
So if you wanna introspect what's already running
as a device without going through the UI,
it's a lot easier to type packet CLI
devices get
and take a look at what's going on
or if you just even want to query
the availability or capacity, which is another really
good API endpoint. In fact, I don't think
I showed that.
Yeah. API is gonna be your go to
for automation
and repeatability. We we showed,
for example, bringing up one machine as opposed
to 10 or a hundred or a thousand.
And while you're sitting in front of it
and, you know, making
handcrafted
artisanal API requests
as opposed to baking those into your product.
The API is used by our our SDKs
if you have a Python program that you
that you want to write and run or
that's your
stack your application is written in.
Also so, the API is used by, tools
like TerraForm
if,
if you're going to bring your,
bring your machines up, using
using the HashiCorp tools.
So,
yeah, definite like, API is probably where most
of the where most of the usage happens,
but being able to try and inspect with
another
with another mechanism you're comfortable and familiar with
is is no trouble at all.
Yeah. And I think it's really pertinent. You
mentioned tools like Terraform and then there's also
Pulumi and Crossplane and all these other libraries
out there. And there are other ways to
spin up Equinix metal devices. Today, thought we
tackle the first three. I'm sure with future
metal Mondays, I'm hoping that name won't stick,
you never know. Then we
are gonna look at all these other tools
too. There's a lot of great ways to
interact with Equinix middle API. And this is
just the
easiest way to get started, I guess, without
having to learn any other tools.
It really is. But like you said, it's
just scratching the surface on what you can
actually do.
Yeah. Definitely.
So we'll give it another one or two
minutes. If you have any questions that you
want us to cover, feel free to drop
that in the comment section and we will
tackle it. As far as other sessions that
we wanna do, like I said, we will
take a look at Terraforms and Pulumi's cross
planes. We will take a look at, you
know, the next step of this. Right now,
we've done a good job of hopefully, hopefully
a good job. I've shown you how to
get a new bare metal device.
But we haven't shown you how to put
it in phononic yet. So, you know, whether
it'd be next week or the week after,
we're gonna show you, okay, how do I
get NGINX running? How do I get Kubernetes
running? How do I get whatever software I
wanna run, running on this device? And there's
a whole bunch of tooling there that we
could show you how to do that too.
And you're actually planning on
playing with a new provider. Right? Live?
Does that happen next month?
So we will be
doing a livestream with the Pulumi team on
November 16.
I don't think we'll be working with a
new provider, but we will be showing you
to do some really cool stuff with Equinix
metal and the Pulumi stack. So more details
on that will be available soon,
but not today. Alright,
I don't think we're gonna get any more
questions.
Nope.
I'm happy to leave it there. So thank
you very much for joining us today. We
will be back. There will be plenty more
information coming your way and we hope to
speak to you all soon. Thank you very
much for joining.
Thanks. Thanks, Macay. Thanks,
Jeff.